I was at that weird kind of transitional
stage where I was still you know playing
14 15 16 years old and I was like 21 and
you know as you know being a child actor
that transition is very hard because
people just kind of want you to stay and
you were a child actor yeah yeah and so
um for me it was it was kind of like a
National Commercial saying I am grown I
am a woman now you know well music
videos were so important oh for sure you
know since that MTV flag landed on that
Moon up until you know very recently
like and they're still very important
but they were everything yeah like that
was yeah they were a huge medium and
format and it's true there is sort of
one way to dispel the I'm a little girl
now and you know being in a cool 50 Cent
video or like for me I did a film called
Poison Ivy it's like you're like
exactly